gang gang buzz buzz crystaly I [ __ ]
love you but sore yeah
you ever met this guy oh I'm the dumb
one you can't argue there's something
about me you have no idea
[Music]
yeah so I don't know somebody gave me
this coat the other night and put a note
in it after a show
I'm really curious about that so is
there a suicide letter
so hold on this is start the start of
the episode obviously but what I want to
know is you came in with that jacket and
then I said I came in with this jacket
yeah and I said cool jacket when did
where uh where did you get it and you
kind of were vague about it and then I
said well how long have you you said I
don't really know I said well how long
have you had it and you said eight days
and I said you forgot where you got it
and you got it eight days ago who did I
did you yes exactly yes and then
everything kind of you know went away we
stopped talking about it and now you're
saying
this guy gave me this jacket and there's
a note in it and it was eight days ago
so I guess my question to you is why
didn't you tell me that when I was
originally asking about the jacket
because it's very weird yes no hate no
nothing just why did you do that yeah
well your honor I was uh uh I think I
was nervous when I came in I didn't know
if
I didn't know exactly if you were what
your motives were
and it was also a woman that gave me the
jacket I will say that sir okay so now
this is changing yeah is that the letter
can you read it because I thought you
stole it from Kid Rock it smells like
gum it smells like gum and something
it's a very cool jacket thank you and
that's why we're asking about it and I
think that's why it kind of alerted you
because yeah
this is hilarious wow there we go all
right so way better just put me in that
seat
I'll be in the back seat so however this
is the note that came with it yeah
please read it it's okay was it
attractive lady before you read this
I'll tell you right now no
yes
see she was hot it wasn't yeah she
couldn't believe that for a second not
this much effort I believe we could find
Deep Beauty here is one of the lines
very sweet also is it me and me rude to
me
don't give it to Eric 100. yeah what the
world as we know it is ending I want to
spend it with you so now her friend this
is the thing you gotta worry about her
friends know and then her friends see
this and their friends make fun of her
with this [ __ ] well I don't think so
it's very private I'm sorry I said that
the world is ending we should be
together Brittany you don't you do not
know if the world's gonna end or not bro
no but I'm saying but don't be that guy
if the world's gonna end and you want to
spend it with
the girl who gave you the jacket yeah
the girl who gave you the jacket yeah
Smart Choice look the lady obviously is
a talented lady and a cool lady well
she's obviously talented unless he wrote
that cool note oh okay well you can't
read any more of the note I'm very I I'm
gonna go ahead and say I don't want to
hear right uh that's what crazy it's
two-page handling I I don't want to
listen to it
no you can't come on and it's not that
you can't but you can let me
let's read this let's read this that's
how he tricks you yeah yeah making it up
because can't read Theo I didn't have
weird word time to write this
time time was the word uh it looks like
the mud okay uh we'll say time I didn't
have time no she says time twice I
didn't have time to write this but
here's what I got the parallel is
between our past life events so there we
know already so right now she's crazy
right right there hit crazy immediately
you think that past lives anyone talk
about past lives is crazy and I'll tell
you this it gets weird why I know it
gets weirder but this is why because it
you she has to understand she's just
meeting you you can't be like hi how you
doing I'm Lisa so past lives yeah you
know you're gonna come off crazy so if
you don't know you're gonna come off
crazy right you have to get that how do
you so how do you get from hey I'm nice
to meet you two past lives how do you
get to there uh probably like months and
months of hanging out you want me keep
going you know that you know weeks you
guys are twins conversation and you you
know it comes up how long does it take
love at first sight give me like 20
minutes
you're just talking all of a sudden I'll
pass lives oh you know what I'm into
past lives you know I don't know can I
continue yeah this could be covered in
Period do you mind I know do you mind
can I continue it's just gonna hurt her
feelings no not at all B our current
lifestyle
are too bizarre for me to ignore the
internal State you speak of is both
similar and com
completely to mine when you describe who
you want it sounds eerily and awfully a
lot like me so I believe we could find
Deep Beauty here yeah I feel we can help
each other and many more thank you drink
this Kool-Aid no no be anything but
Earnest the world as we know it is
ending I want to send spend it with you
a number IG
very sweet I think no it is sweet so
when you end up dead in a month I don't
think she's crazy I think she wants to
wear your face mask he can dive by her
hands so and that's fine but we know
it's gonna happen
you think if I went out with that girl
that competition until you die you could
you could potentially do that but I will
tell you this but I would tell you
she'll end up pregnant
I think that's more in line of what is
about to happen who's most likely in
this room to knock up someone that is
absolutely Bonkers that is a good
question Nick and this girl sounds like
a beautiful girl to me Nick I said [ __ ]
meet some chick at a sports book yeah
you know what I mean they both have
gambling Bros
some girl that loves OTV so much she
brings a saddle in from her car and puts
it on the school
what's OTB am I dumb huh it's just a
place people go to have fun in poor
communities it's called off track
betting
him and his girl trying to decide for
[ __ ] bet on the game
yeah that baby loves Kansas
who would knock up somebody crazy would
you
I don't know I believe you haven't to be
honest and here's the thing if I haven't
at this point I haven't who in here may
have knocked up someone that's
absolutely crazy out on the road and is
it hiding it and we have no idea
definitely not me the American Girl
Dakota oh I almost I had almost what
happened semi running with this girl
nice girl
pretty talk about this before uh-uh
she wanted to have the baby we ended up
making love and she wanted to have the
baby she got pregnant but she didn't but
she said she felt pregnant and when
somebody's Native Americans
she did a rain dancing
you met the Rat King didn't you
the Rat King has put a seed inside I
smell cheese
so what we've done ow what we know
though is that you met a very a nice
beautiful young lady and you didn't use
a condom never or did you never I don't
know if I did or not so I know that no I
know you did it yeah if you don't know
you did or nothing you know you did I
would bet that I may not have right okay
just feeling it uh I don't know right
here meatball's your son it could have
been the time of year or something I was
like just feeling kind of fancy free hmm
but I remember she said I'm having I'm
having this child it was like the first
thing she said after she left this
Fairfield Inn her heart went
oh I was like and I was downstairs and
they were doing construction I remember
at this Fairfield Inn in Suites and I'm
like oh I can't even couldn't even get
like a meal I just [ __ ] felt so just
alone and then also the reservation to
get where she lived you had to do a
layover and I was like oh yeah yeah yeah
so okay so she said I feel like he won't
do a connection flight for his kids
[ __ ] won't do this deadbeat dad
so because it's difficult to get there
you like I ain't never gonna see my kid
cuz I can't get on a little plane look
let's just say I'll get a tattoo that
says Zoom Daddy on my arm
name of the episode
so you were gonna we're Stevia is he
[ __ ] here
so you were gonna you were gonna have
she was gonna have it but she didn't
have it no she just felt it immediately
as soon as you did you by the way did
you go inside
oh yeah you did no I didn't I've never
done that okay so you've never done that
I'm never doing it pulled out so you
pulled out never done that I better
believe you so you thought maybe you got
some cheeks thought maybe you got some
pre you leaked dinner I don't know there
was a lot of nerves there's always a lot
there was just a nervous situation oh
nerves but here's the thing though now
did her attitude change immediately
because it feels like she wanted to get
pregnant yeah oh she was sending me like
bit emojis of like [ __ ] cash and like
a little Kettle and [ __ ] like that like
she was [ __ ] I think thinking about
it's a new Dreamcast changing her game
yeah so right after she was like and I'm
pregnant
she texted me in the car on the way
afterwards yeah okay she texted the
guard and said what I feel like I'm
pregnant and what did you say LOL no I
said oh God but but Theo this was an
hour after you [ __ ] humped yeah man
yeah when you know you know it was yeah
it was probably 50 minutes when you know
you know and then what please and then
she said and she had like a long drive
home it was like seven hours because
reservations are out I mean they're yeah
they put them unfortunately in some
pretty they put him wherever yeah and so
she is like cruising back there and then
she said yeah she said uh you know I
won't know obviously for a little while
but and then we kind of gotten I think I
called her or whatever and we just got
into a discussion I said well if you
were pregnant would you have a child you
know and what would you feel like about
that and she said I would have a child
and what's crazy is uh your son's
zooming in Tonto Vaughn come on in
[Laughter]
time
he looks just like me dad but with a
mullet
that could be the episode title but yeah
it was just shocking man you never had
an experience like that no no I had a
girl lie about she was pregnant uh and
uh her and then her sister told me like
don't worry she's lying to you and I was
like well how do you know and she said
because she is getting married and I had
no idea and I was like what yeah I mean
this was [ __ ] 15 years ago yeah yeah I
mean [ __ ] that's a [ __ ] up joke anyway
on somebody or you know I don't know
what you want a bad person yeah yeah
it was alarming I I and pardon me I'd
love to have a child that's Native
American or no Native American yeah
either or but it was just a shocking
month you know I just didn't know
sometimes I wish that we'd had that you
know I had a child
so well you don't have to wish that hard
you could just have one you know yeah
well yeah
or you can just adopt a kid and have it
and just be the dad and the kid would
that be cool but the adoption is Pursuit
of Happiness I would maybe foster a
child because that's like you get to
kind of test drive it a little you're
picked but I think a few to adopt some
people adopted not a rush and stuff it
gets real Russian it gets risque I've
heard a lot of things yeah a lot of uh
Dr Ryan's remorse
he means like a full-grown 19 year old
yeah hello Dad how are you
hello Dad where do I put my car keys
I have my bags if you like to return me
you have 30 days
you must take it up with the Russian
government but well but it's nice to
meet you Dad
he just wants to wrestle all the time
and [ __ ] yeah that's Vlad Von yeah yeah
yeah yeah Dmitry Bond
let's take another little break from the
show and we will get right back to it
because you're pushing your body hard
man whether you're doing a thick Mudder
you're busting your ass in the gym on
dead lifts you're hitting that cardio
you're probably you feel run down a
little bit maybe you're just grinding
man you run down you need some hydration
you gotta stay hydrated that's where my
boys at liquid IV they got you covered
man liquid IV hydration multiplier it's
16 ounces of water hydrates you two
times faster all right than water alone
and it's delicious they got watermelon
lemon lime strawberry pina colada and so
much more watermelon is my favorite by
far one stick of liquid IV and 16 ounce
of water hydrates faster like I told you
way faster than water contains five
essential vitamins B3 B5 B6 B12 and
vitamin C and they have three times
electrolytes of your traditional sports
drink with all that Sugar you don't need
all that men non-GMO we got you covered
man it is designed to get in your body
and absorb so much faster in the
bloodstream so you feel great man a
little hungover maybe like your boy
right now a little hungover get some
liquid IV and you pop you perk back up
all right we got you man grab liquid IV
and bulk nationwide at Costco or you can
get 25 off when you go to liquid iv.com
use the code Kats at checkout that's 25
off anything you order when you use the
promo code Kats at Lucid liquid iv.com
all right experience better hydration
just be smarter about it liquid iv.com
promo code Kats now let's get back to
the shenanigans the NBA playoff is here
kids the Celtics up to zero my net my
Nets I'm not from Brooklyn but I'm a fan
of Kevin Durant I think they're gonna
win game three but listen you're
watching the game with your boys you got
to make Bank bro you can do that with
draftking Sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the NBA this week new
customers can bet five dollars on any
team to win and get one hundred and
fifty dollars in free bets instantly you
win no matter what all DraftKings
Sportsbook customers can also bet on NBA
Hoops with the same game parlays your
boy is a fan of parlays combine multiple
bets from the same game for a bigger
payout the more legs you add the more
you can win I don't like to go more than
three plus each day of the first round
get a risk-free bet up to ten dollars if
your same game parlay doesn't hit
download the DraftKings Sportsbook app
now you promo code Kats bet five dollars
on any NBA team to win their game during
the first round of playoffs and get one
hundred and fifty dollars in free bets
instantly that's promo code Kats at
draftking Sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the NBA minimum age
and eligibility restrictions apply see
show notes for details DraftKings
Sportsbook all right let's get into this
man but I'm sure Eric you've had a scare
I'm sure over the years over so many
years yeah
I've had a couple scares yeah have you
yeah people like it's alive yeah it's I
think it's the kind of thing it's weird
how it happens like immediately after
where it's just kind of like this
you know like I and you realize oh you
trying to have a baby yeah yeah yeah
yeah you know what I mean yeah that's
you got to be careful you can't trust
any any any like hey I'm on the pill or
you know I can't believe you went wrong
yeah going raw that's uh
your black side came out your black side
came out
yeah but it'd be feeling good this is
how we do it I don't know I think that's
interesting thing too you're just like I
need to fill you up oh man you don't get
to meet a lot of Native Americans
they're willing to make love to you and
so to not to go back to your roots
especially with a white devil yeah you
remember the rad King
but of all the somebody drove seven at
you like you're in a town doing stand-up
yeah and then did she come to the show
she stayed over yeah she came she's oh I
don't even know if she stayed open so
she drove back seven hours at night
through the night that's super Indian
her native name was like open eyes or
something midnight
I think I'm pregnant
this writing isn't
as a child
why isn't she on speaker like why did
she have yeah she has a little one of
those on the back of the horse's head
get an Uber driver yeah y'all are sick
man
no dude no there's another Native
American tribe again and she's in the
background
that's a Uber
I think we look I'd love to be Native
American I'd love to have a Native
American yeah well we can make that
happen yeah and if Americans are are uh
they're great if you had to choose you'd
you'd go white You'd Stay white I don't
know man I'm 1 8 Pontiac dude and I I
think that's helpful huh no try brother
Google Pontiac tribe brother Chand Deuce
you're not one-eighth of the place that
you got conceived you know what I mean
I'm one of these Chevelle yeah
yeah I'm uh one six Dodge Neon
like your Dodge Neon
Pontiac right there cool on the Naomi
River that's your dad right there on the
right wow it could be it's pretty it
looks pretty white open eyes Vaughn
Brennan has a locket of him too
it's on the back side of his
dude I wish the fight do you think if
the if the whites would have fought
hand-to-hand combat with the Native
Americans they would have beat him or no
hand to hand and not use weapon no way
yeah probably not no no way dude we
outnumber yeah but if you had to do same
numbers
well but that's just a lot of ifs and
I'm grateful for this code and the lady
that gave it to you no yeah hopefully
she's still if she doesn't kill you it's
worth it if she kills you it wasn't
worth it and you didn't wash it or
anything you just put it straight on no
from the mail room what city did she
give that does that farm to table it's a
gray hair
it is great this is Farm to Table baby
it's her dad's jacket she jacked and
that thing gave it to you dang pubic too
yeah
cool jacket I'll tell you this much
if she doesn't kill you it's worth
everything
I don't know if it's worth it what's
this guy want Nick
it looks like Calvin a little bit a
little bit all my kids look like
a Brandon Theo said Chris got a question
for you guys this kid doesn't give a
[ __ ] about thinking of starting this
little dude in wrestling yeah
yeah and gymnastics so that's the
question for today
kids gymnastics kid King in her stick is
faded energy
so he probably listens to juice world he
might be perked up he's cute yeah my son
wouldn't sit like that for one second
he'd be punching and running well you're
not they're not showing the video before
this where their dad was like don't move
yeah yeah yeah yeah
finally just like wore him down I think
it's great to get yeah he looks too
young for it too young I think it's
great to get look at like oh he does
look a little bit like you there's
Calvin
look how excited he gets they do look
similar he's so cute Dude Looks Like
Your Wife man don't say that man he
looks like me man that's what I do I
don't know his blonde hair like your
wife he doesn't really look like you no
he looks like me man really yeah the
eyebrows look at this parts of him look
like Chris you could be looking oh God
he doesn't have your nose Jesus Christ
well yeah mine was probably small back
then too dude
same size nose yeah yeah that kid
I'll tell you this they thought you were
one of those breech babies but it was
your nose what's this guy asking if this
is his son or not it's a boy or girl I
don't know yet I hope it's a boy I hope
it's a boy uh I don't you can't really
start kids in Jitsu until they're four
gymnastics he said he said he said the
two Engineers
wrestling we had a Jutsu hat on but you
can't start him under four so you got
some time the kid might be too too young
well I like I'll wrestle like I'll just
because I because one thing about I
remember like I was always like wincing
at [ __ ] when I was a kid like because my
dad was never like he wouldn't like
throw me around and [ __ ] still money at
your face no and so and so when I she's
like hey playing this bowl of quarters
Chris's dad was like doing like this
I'll Make It Rain a little [ __ ] Make It
Rain [ __ ] this has paper cuts all over
his face
I am doing good
so uh so
um what was I saying so sorry so so when
I got into Jiu Jitsu like when I was 19
that was when I realized oh it's fun to
like [ __ ] wrestle with dudes and [ __ ]
but I hated it before that so I want to
make sure that my son is like cool with
that you and your brother never like
fought in this kid not really man dude
he would smoke his brother though yeah I
would uh yeah I would be I mean well now
especially but like but my mice I want
to like wrestle my son but so he hates
it right he's like he doesn't like it
not yet no but he's two I bring him over
the house let Boston get his hands on
them so what so what yeah so what does
Boston doing Boston Market
Boston securities
I'll walk in the house and he'll just
he'll like get down and want to wrestle
yeah he wrestles non-stop oh you're
gonna be in the principal's office a lot
oh yeah and when you realize nobody
wants to wrestle he starts twerking I do
notice that the dude no dude I'm trying
to so my son excels in wrestling he's in
Jitsu but he just takes everybody down
so I'm like oh would you want to do like
a kid's wrestling program he's like yeah
I'd love that so I'm looking for one in
Calabasas if there's a good wrestling
program kids program in Calabasas holler
at your boy and you do and you do this
and he's two what he's he uh Tiger's six
but he doesn't oh you're talking about
Tiger Tiger does it twice a week Boston
will start when he's four yeah okay so
that's what I'm talking about Boston
because he's two same age but he'll
wrestle right now bring Calvin over
we're going to Boston we'll wrestle him
right now Doug yeah all right yeah but
what happens like you guys are watching
your kids yeah and then one of them
starts like just [ __ ] the other one
up oh well I'll stop like what are you
guys I would stop if my son was doing
that to somebody I would stop I y'all
finish him
do you guys have like a moment where
you're looking at each other like hey
dude kind of nah I I get your kid people
you know you everyone parents
differently but dude I see people's kids
at the playground and I'm like no I'm
like get the [ __ ] kid doing that [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah the kid's just like and
grab something it's like hey Calvin we
don't do that you know what I mean like
do that yeah the parents that just don't
regulate their kid especially if they're
bad kids like Boston was playing in the
sand and this little kid came up and sat
down I'm like oh that's cute it's just
throwing sand in his face in Boston's
face yeah look at the cat I'm like dude
you're gonna do something like oh
there's this kid I'm like okay tiger and
then he comes over he's throwing Santa
in your brother's face you don't stand
for it or turn that kid into the mummy
the Tiger's like Guru or Google
the shop is gonna be the little bully
kids right there man or Doyle rules
account I gotta crawl up uh I gotta call
up tiger yeah
wow you know what up cats all right yeah
let's do it is that what's the comic is
that Taylor Thompson uh this is Annie
Taylor Letterman's actually from
Missouri and I'm coming at you with the
King and her sing it keeping your dead
relatives ashes in this bag right here I
put them on my sandwiches is my mom
oh oh she died in August and um she just
been living in my closet ever since oh I
don't know what to do with her because
she's my mom you know uh do I throw her
ashes in a river
do I keep him in a closet do I buy a
fancy yarn
I don't know you know it's all I got
left over what do I do oh do I just
become a human hoarder
board you know chucker well my question
is I understand keeping them
thanks guys love all three of you so
much
thanks for everything you do oh there's
four of us but anyway
um my question is did she have to pay
extra for that bag you know what I mean
like you go to the store and they're
like yeah would you like a bag they
charge you know or is that does she
bring her oh no it says funeral home
yeah yeah that's what I'm saying yeah a
lot of times I know they'll give you the
bags at the funeral home hmm they don't
give them to you at Whole Foods that's
what I'm saying that Whole Foods
70 [ __ ] items do you need a bag nah
[ __ ] I'll just [ __ ] you know nah
that's why I brought my cargo no I'm
just gonna [ __ ] hoard it like this
it's cheaper to get somebody it's
cheaper to get somebody grilled than to
get whole food I mean it's it's I think
look you got to do something nice with
them I think you put them out in a
beautiful dish or you put them out in a
um
beautiful
um
somewhere well I don't understand this
place you mean to tell me that your
parent whoever dies they put him in a
little to-go box and a little that's
kind of weird and then they just gave it
to you like that
knife
is this important thing yeah it comes
with a little salt and pepper thing
you're like I feel like that funeral
home could do better yeah yeah maybe she
didn't maybe you have to spring for the
vase though I don't know
I think I think that you first of all
it's Gilbert huh let me just say it's
it's R.I.P it's not all that you have
left of her what you have left of her
are the memories and that's a beautiful
thing right yeah so you do have
something regardless of what happens
with these ashes
um but if you want to do something nice
do something nice if you know my whole
thing is like to to keep them and put
them on in a vase that's cool you know
if you want to put on The Mantel but
then it's like you're always thinking
about it yeah it's always in your face
yeah it's always your face so what
whatever your mom liked to do whether it
was [ __ ] if she'd like to go to the
beach or down the ocean put them in the
kitchen Costco right outside of Costco
sprinkle them into the firefighter
fireworks and [ __ ] light that [ __ ]
them all a lot of moms like to go to the
mall you could take them over to the
mall take them over to Aunt Annie's or
take them over to uh
fountain in the mall
with the kids toss coins in yeah that's
like the ghetto water park it'd be so
dope if every time you went to the mall
you knew your mom was in there it's
pretty cool it's really cool or take
them to a park or something like that
throw them in Boston's eyes yeah you
could do that if you want to get beat up
by Tiger throw them in uh or put them in
a park or something put them in the
Cinnabon icing everybody shares your mom
I just don't like that idea because what
if you go to put it in a park and then
they [ __ ] excavate the park like
three years later and you're like wow
that's that's an extra heart heartache
and it's a Capital One anyway but in the
ocean I know it is but
that ocean is good scary but don't ever
if I die you ask me
no don't make it pretty
throw me right in between like a
driveway and a [ __ ] trash can and
have someone kill me please I want to be
a dateline I want to at least create a
one uh it starts with that jacket you
know that yeah yeah
yeah
and got a NASCAR jacket yeah and a note
inside
but what about that jacket yeah yeah
yeah yeah
sure sure the jacket was nice murder
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh should we see what this guy has to
say yeah it was August nice time for a
jacket it was a little hot sure but that
wasn't the only weird thing about boring
this is like Santino
Chris and Theo sitting on some free
merch Von
got a king it or sting it for you fellas
today
I mean where the [ __ ] is he going he's
in Chichen Itza dog
snorkeling in an underground spring no
that looks [ __ ] awesome you guys do
it
no this thing's 40 plus feet underground
to the top of the water
and then it goes down another
60 feet
until you get to the base of it that's
awesome did they shoot the Avengers
there that's awesome
where is he Mexican do you guys think
huh
that's crazy that just there's that
staircase naturally there gang gang buzz
buzz solar jump in that way oh I'm sure
they do wow that's where I wonder where
that is we would do that I'll do it I
think it might be Mexico they're called
yeah usually that's in Mexico I would do
that unless we don't know what kind of
fish are there if you knew all the fish
I'd do it yeah because I'm not going you
don't want anything dangerous what do
you mean like if you knew each one like
there's Rebecca not personally Henry I'm
just saying the style of fish the
species I'm not going in where they're
like oh okay we don't know though what
because it could be a hammerhead like a
turban or snake or whatever yeah exactly
I was in new I was in uh the Cook
Islands in off of New Zealand oh damn
and then the uh it's Rich
they're telling you like hey uh you know
well you can go swimming but no no
there's this certain fish look out for
yeah yeah I'm out yeah yeah yeah you
know what I mean oh yeah I'll be able to
tell what that one is anytime you feel
anything yeah something just rubs up
against you you're like this is it you
know what I mean yeah damn what were you
doing out there oh
and if I'm even swimming and I touch one
of my feet with my other feet out there
I'm out the wall yeah I hate that [ __ ] I
don't feel that [ __ ] slap like the
slap of it like the meaty slap [ __ ] all
that even with just some seaweed
anything like that even water scares me
it's so scary bro when you get out in
the ocean this [ __ ] is scary it's so
scary bro yeah because it's another
Universe dude imagine if a fish was just
cruising through the air right here for
no reason yeah I know somebody would hit
it with a bat or a [ __ ] rake or a
sword yeah they don't know all the fish
in the water no we know more about space
than we do the ocean yeah dude bye bye
bye water I'll go knee-deep at best dude
oh you don't know all the fish think
about if they LED with that yeah you
want to go in the ocean and you're an
alien what is that oh yeah it's in there
what's in there we don't know bye-bye
back to your planet do it there's no way
back to Russia yup yes
oh I don't want none of that baby what
is it there's one hit them lip headers I
don't want that your lips built for it
yeah but it makes fun it makes my
[ __ ] body hurt your your lips built
for it that's true what is it what is it
called rogue rogue your lip is built for
it yeah that's a good slope it is
your lips are built for rogue [ __ ]
Rogue you're not doing anything with
your [ __ ] mouth yeah put this in it
yeah [ __ ] yeah you're just standing
there not talking just mouth all limp
your lips built for roads yeah yeah yeah
oh your veins are happy and peaceful
right now won't let you fill them with
these [ __ ] chemicals you
[Laughter]
just want to let you guys know that May
7th we've added a show over there in Los
Angeles you can come check that out
thank you uh May 18th I'll be in
Albuquerque 19th Midland Texas
in May 20 in Lubbock Texas May 21 Dallas
we've added a second show there
June 2 in Savannah GA June 3 in Augusta
GA June 4 Montgomery Alabama in June 5
Columbus GA
as well some new dates going up right
now June 23rd Hollywood Florida
June 24th Fort Myers Florida June 25th
Daytona Beach Florida and June 26th
Lakeland Florida and those Florida dates
are all available all dates are
available at theovan.com tour
and the Florida dates
um those go on sale 10 a.m local
uh
uh and that they they may need the code
Rat King I'm not sure when you're
hearing this but if there's a promo code
or an access code it's Rat King
and uh and I'm looking forward to seeing
you guys maybe gang gang
all right let's take a little break from
chatting with these freaks all right
because the NBA playoff is here kids the
Celtics up 2-0 my Nets my Nets I'm from
Brooklyn but I'm a fan of Kevin Durant I
think they're gonna win game three but
listen you're watching the game with
your boys you got to make Bank bro you
can do that with draftking Sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
NBA this week new customers can bet five
dollars on any team to win and get one
hundred and fifty dollars in free bets
instantly you win no matter what all
DraftKings Sportsbook customers can also
bet on NBA Hoops with the same game
parlays your boy is a fan of parlays
combine multiple bets from the same game
for a bigger payout the more legs you
add the more you can win I don't like to
go more than three plus each day of the
first round get a risk-free bet up to
ten dollars if your same game parlay
doesn't hit download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app now use promo code Kats
bet five dollars on any NBA team to win
their game during the first round of
playoffs and get one one hundred and
fifty dollars in free bets instantly
that's promo code Kats at draftking
Sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the NBA minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply see show
notes for details DraftKings Sportsbook
all right fellas or ladies you're out
there looking for the perfect gift for
that special moment whatever it is it's
a birthday and an anniversary it's an
engagement ring of her or his dreams
right it's 2022 let's be cool man you
gotta give them Timeless jewelry you
just have to but you need it at a good
price that's why my friends at Blue Nile
are making this so easy man all right
they have fine jewelry diamond jewelry
cocktail rings tennis bracelets they
have gold layering jewelry they got it
all man whatever gift you're looking for
Mother's Day is coming up man maybe you
got a wife and you got kids you got your
mom you got a girlfriend a mother
mother-in-law grandmother they're all
gonna want something dude so you don't
want to go broke but you want it to be
nice blue now got you covered man you
gotta celebrate life special moments
with fine jewelry looking for Fine
Jewelry but having trouble choosing
blue now man they have experts then
they're there 24 7 available via phone
or chat to help you find exactly what
you're looking for at your budget
Mother's Day like I told you it's coming
up you got to get them something fly all
right maybe you want some diamond stud
earrings a tennis bracelet what are you
looking for you gotta check out
bluenile.com all right and the king and
the sting in the wing listeners get
fifty dollars off 500. this is a king
the sting and the wing exclusive it's
only good through Mother's Day so use
the code Kats that's code k-a-t-s plus
every order is insured ships free
arrives in discreet little package so
your mom won't know what's inside if you
do live with your mom all right shop
stress free and find your Forever piece
go to bluenow.com today
yeah
this guy's got an appropriate uh for
straights or gays
yeah straight engaged boy or whatever
your pronouns are there's a lot of
violent gays out there too man dude I
got my haircut by the most violent gay
dude man is that what happened he's so
angry he [ __ ] it all up hmm you didn't
say [ __ ] though you're scared huh no I
honestly felt bad for him something was
wrong with him man he was mentally
unwell a fellow named Michael was it in
an Alleyway or you got yeah where was
this
we got a legit Salon or someplace like
how was a mentally unwell person working
at a little much been having a bad day
yeah something's wrong with him though
but he didn't like straight look that
was still getting his haircut
yeah he was some little freaking Coke
penguin and he didn't like straight
all right what was that [ __ ]
Shawshank the musical yeah Redemption it
was just a bit shitty picture from oh oh
look on this lady boys what a great
movie The sister sisters
what's up guys huge fan been listening
forever uh I've done fan art all three
you guys and you're posting your stories
a couple times so thank you that's sick
um on my way home from work right now in
the car so Nick's probably gonna like
this one I hear he likes those car
submissions
um King inner singing for you uh
nicotine sticks Nick sticks uh Jewels
um
the flavored ones though my girlfriend
does it she says she's not addicted
she's pissing me the [ __ ] off because
she's just always sucking on this thing
she's all flavored smoke it smells damn
good yeah no it doesn't I'll give him
that too much my sister and a boyfriend
they're doing all the time everyone I
work with sucking on them all day
I tried them they taste not good Jesus
you're gonna try the right one Doug
you're already out there buddy like we
don't know what he's talking about like
if he could be talking about dicks the
way he's talking about it everybody's
sucks
it smells good doesn't taste that good
of the people in your neighborhood doing
it Eric
and my neighbors my whole family's doing
it
the Culver City Marina Del Rey area yeah
right okay yeah
I am they vaping over there man
everybody my girl was vaping I hate that
[ __ ] people Vape around me dude it makes
my tongue fat I'm telling you oh yes
it's bad for you brother it's a dirt it
is a chemical there's chemicals in it
well yeah you can tell because of the
way it smells wow I don't know if that's
why but well I do they're not making it
with reels yeah what do you think
they're cram and strawberries in that
thing yeah dude yes for some of them
yeah no way it's delicious
I think isn't there some plant-based
ones you have a Skittle one yeah
[ __ ] tobacco raw nicotine big
difference yeah but I will tell you this
the nicotine you know tobacco business
figure out those e-cigarettes then when
they Market it with Skittles and
Starbursts all the kids are doing them
now uh high school it's all over this
big pancake would eat his own Cooter if
he could hell yeah dog yeah it sucks
that they do Market these things for
[ __ ] children
look at it they make it like oh look at
this little gun I think Calvin would
look at that and I'm on it and a kid can
even hit it there's videos of kids
hitting them YouTube kids hitting Jewel
that's not good or Jewel hitting kids
and I tell you what it is the singer
just [ __ ] smacking five girls
I don't know Orleans Avenue
in 10 years it's gonna be one of those
things where it's like were you smoking
a jewel and you have a class action
lawsuit that's what's gonna happen yeah
and but do you think that more people
smoke now than before that's what I
wanted no not at all I do think so you
consider Jewel smoking
undeniably
they're just nicotine yeah it's nicotine
it's supposed to be way worse for you
too oh okay so who are you arguing for
yeah you just yeah can you think you're
smoking yeah can you help us be worse
too
he's never picked us up once again
no oh yeah let's turn it up 13 year old
30 cigarettes a day yeah oh he's
straight smoking cigarettes though you
guys a [ __ ] Legend wow the music and
the music that's young king Dave baby
this young Cheddar Bob here man where's
his parents huh around what do you mean
their drivers are going to get him no
they're dead bro
well we knew he was from okay he wants
to be addicted
nobody wants to be a dude
oh he seems happy yeah now he's gonna
die in 10 minutes
Teletubbies my favorite new PAW Patrol
oh my God my favorite turtles yeah I
Love Despicable Me yeah dude first of
all how much have you had to smoke that
you are casually laying down smoking
yeah dude I smoked for like nine years
and I never casually was laying on a bed
[ __ ] smoking
somebody changed my diaper yeah the
school lunch today look at this kid it's
a great Gap camera commercial right
there I bet he does I bet he takes bets
for uh Joe Joyce and them
wow look at the kid with this blurred
out face oh him and his boys just
smoking I bet he's a [ __ ] Jesus I
can't believe they have 48 minutes of
this yeah I'm good after him
click forward I want to see him smoke a
little bit quick forward he's 13. oh
he's on a swing smoking just no cardio
he's already tired
this is cardio and dub in Ireland keep
it moving forward he's trying to be a
kid but he's also trying to smoke them
cigs let's see him Huff a little art is
uh the guy has a great life honestly and
he kind of crushed it good he's gonna be
short well this is what I'm saying so
then we're like if he's on horses and
[ __ ] you can't be getting better see
this is the part oh he went to rehab
oh that's good man these people couldn't
be anything but British huh look at the
mom you saw oh he's not British you
think he's our uh Scottish
Governor wow yeah Scottish people love
to [ __ ] up
oh she's got Chris's nose I like this
I think I'm the only person who's ever
done a show in Glasgow eh yeah yeah [ __ ]
yeah you guys have done shows in Dublin
over there nope
I would do it hey uh the cervix called
and wants both of you okay your [ __ ]
nah dude take it back nah dude I won't
take it back dude I like your necklaces
okay wow why am I getting this [ __ ] yeah
he didn't even say anything because he
didn't do a show in glass I would go to
Glasgow yeah would you but you haven't
yeah no I haven't yeah they tried to get
me to go
somebody
flipped on him again this guy's [ __ ]
what's his name uh what's that who's the
Mormon flip-flopper the Mormon
politician who's Elizabeth Smart no no
that's way wrong who's the Mormon
politician how many are you talking
about uh Romney close no no no yeah
Romney yeah Romney all right uh so we
got somebody who's ashamed I saw him at
a diner once Mitt Romney yeah it was the
diners huh well he was having him he's a
he's a Mormon Republican but then he
doesn't really vote that's a thing yeah
he lives in La Jolla
oh wait I buy that he certainly looks
like someone who lives in La Jolla
that's hilarious yeah we got some uh
cats confessions some parents get some
stuff off their chest a gang gang but
but Thor how do you like my jacket I got
one of them concessions for you uh back
when I was 16 so about nine years ago I
was dating a girl and I was backing out
of her driveway about say 1am and I
smashed into her mom's car I mean I
rear-ended that thing with my truck but
the huge old Dent if I had an old truck
so it didn't really scratch my [ __ ] up
you know what I did I took off baby
everybody was asleep so uh confessions
hit and run on my ex-girlfriend's mom
Debbie I apologize for rude in your
Honda but your daughter just doctored
himself bro and she cheated on me so I
don't feel too bad about it don't talk
about it something but uh hit and run
gang gang that's literal Karma yeah car
uh hit and run
[Music]
you finally hit your sting he got it
hit and run I say look it's happening
Costello right here I love it yeah
buddy you smashing the whole family now
dude you smashing indoors you smashing
outdoors I think leave a note bro if
you'd have gone an extra step and left a
note I've been gangster and put [ __ ]
y'all hey remember that time I didn't
cheat yet oh but here's what I would
have said yeah that's yeah oh that's a
good point if the girl cheated I would
have said sorry and did by who the guy
she cheated with yeah sorry sorry this
is for Daniel yeah sorry sorry about
your car but this was Daniel's fault no
whatever she cheats you go back you
leave a note and you say remember the
accident it was me and you know I wanted
to admit it because your daughter
[ __ ] cheated on me wow now that is
the move I think you go over there and
videotape that and do a Skype with us
yep
um by the way hit and run is always
don't not a good thing no let's just say
that I don't know it's not taking this
thing he's just getting it off and of
course I thought he said King his thing
didn't he no no one has to co-sign it's
an old-fashioned move yeah yeah
and I know why you know you're saying
that too I mean you got a Ferrari you
know oh man [ __ ] imagine you get come
back to the parking lot and you just see
like a side of your car wreck oh hell no
I mean that happened with that car oh
yeah and you know why they left because
it was like they saw a Ferrari and they
were like I have insurance but [ __ ]
sorry there's someone right in your
Ferrari yeah when I first got it it was
parked it came back and it was [ __ ] up
[ __ ] I wonder who that was
just tell me one thing was it you I'll
just tell you this dude if I have to
take a connecting flight to get to it
um
I love my son dude no we're getting this
jacket if he's alive he gets this coat
God imagine Theo's son imagine if you
had one yeah but Theo's son living on a
reservation this whole time he's like
even worse Theo yeah he's like five you
know yeah he's like freaking like dude
just make a decision you overthink
everything just make the [ __ ]
dreamcatcher yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's great she was like what if but
the girl
podcast every week like he knows yeah
yeah yeah yeah so he's like being him
well I remember I talked about on my
podcast and she heard it and she got
upset oh she's not gonna like this I
didn't mention her name or nothing and I
you know she knows
yeah you said she was an open eyes yeah
open eyes is [ __ ] pissed off now yeah
yeah he's just saying overthinking [ __ ]
on this this weekend
smoking a pipe just yeah
she's mad at her Blackjack job you know
what I mean yeah yeah yeah yeah
he did like he's coming out of a little
sweat lodge
I think that'd be cute
and um
slept with someone
and then went out that night and then I
may have lunch with someone else and I
also may have been close friends
am I a bad person
well it depends what they I wouldn't
care I mean would you guys I actually
played the wrong one too okay let me
know what you think about her so she
slept with two friends yeah yeah
whatever it's more of the friends like
hey dude you know yeah hooked up with if
it was just a random thing I think you
can do it if you have to do it
you guys are eskimo Bros get weird as
[ __ ] about that [ __ ] though man you know
like people get in their feelings about
that like I was like what I was just
with her it depends if your buddy was
like dating and then and then your best
friend was around it doesn't double her
that's frown upon but she's just some
random chick it doesn't sound like that
what does it sound like it's not like
she went back to her hometown and these
are people that she knows these are
people because she don't live there
normally but she moved out so she came
back doesn't sound like she was dating
any of them she just got no one they
were obviously in things things she's
worried it feels like she's worried
about coming off as like [ __ ] you're
only a [ __ ] if you think you aren't you
know what I mean guys don't give a [ __ ]
if girls like yeah [ __ ] them who cares
and I [ __ ] another guy who cares
you're not really a [ __ ] if you're like
no I'm a good girl and you're doing this
kind of [ __ ] yeah then that's what a
[ __ ] is to me dude but if you get to own
it if you get horizontal with one dude
and then late at night at the bar you're
feeling yourself you're having some
drinks and [ __ ] closing time comes on
and you want to get [ __ ] horizontal
with another dude your favorite do what
you want yeah
housing time
this is the one I meant to play okay hey
guys I've been trying to get this off
much lately uh what an animal the water
filter
um
but the water filter uh on my
refrigerator when it says replace my
fiancee pitches about it about the water
takes my [ __ ] even though we have a
double filter hard lined in the back
that I hooked up when we moved into the
brand new house
but uh I didn't change it by resetting
it with the settings I don't actually
change the filter but yep she doesn't
know that and then the water tastes fine
all of a sudden it's weird thanks guys
love the show keep it up gang gang
that's cold and I think that's called
thank you brother for making the call
and sorry you've been going through that
I think that is
going through you lying imagine every
time watching his wife drink water and
knowing he's living a double life oh
dude and she's just ah and he's just
like yeah but no because she's going but
this one how do you like the water but
this is why she's doing it though
because she's all like thank you yeah
yeah yeah you know what I mean you
needed to change this yeah the water
tastes so much better and he's just
looking at her like in her head he's
just like if you only knew [ __ ]
like he wants to tell her yeah oh for
sure you know what I mean he wants to be
like oh you know that water
but he's got that in his back pocket she
cheats he goes like this
[Laughter]
you did what
oh yeah well you know the water you've
been Drinking For Three
unfiltered
but also just change the filter
just change your filter I have one of
those things too it's like a you know
you just unscrew it you put that one in
and it's done like what what you know
what you know why you don't wanna yeah
you don't want to do it all right always
chicks always be telling you what to do
you know and he just wants to not can I
just [ __ ] play Madden you know what
she's like you said you would and he
goes okay
[ __ ] dude yeah he wants to uh also he
don't like doing uh handy stuff probably
around the house he wants to lie about
the filter or it's very funny I think to
know every time someone's drinking water
that you imagine how much joy that is
every time you hear them in the other
room make the clicking sound into the
thing and hit the ice hits you are dying
instant satisfaction one time when I
lived in Burbank I had to enjoy it honey
how's your water [ __ ]
um I lived in Burbank with a Brother's
sister and um the sister uh had the big
room and she had a uh well I'll tell
this one first I would go in and every
day or so I'd take her poster and lower
it an inch and a half
and until like it was super low
but she didn't notice because it was so
gradual and she was and at the same time
I would go anytime I had to go to the
bathroom number two I would go in her
bathroom I wouldn't flush it and I would
walk over to my bathroom and wipe so I I
would just leave I don't give a [ __ ]
wrong gangster right in Burbank wait
wait wait wait wait wait go ahead
questions did you like you know you had
your pants down and water or you didn't
pull them up nobody was home okay
but so so you can also hold your butt
open and walk yeah yeah pretty much what
I did but so um
so she asked me she was like did you not
all this is like a really weird question
but like
do you take shits in my bathroom when
I'm not here and I said huh and she said
yeah do you take shits in my bathroom
when I'm not here and I was like no
maybe you forgot to flush she said
she said yeah but
there's no toilet paper yeah but
there's no toilet paper in there and I I
always wipe it's just and I was die and
I said you mean there's just shits in
there
oh my God that's so diabolical dude it
is
he's a psychological warfare yeah I know
because she's looking in the toilet like
there's first of all this is just a
tremendous amount of [ __ ] in here dude
and she would go and see that until
she'd come out and she'd be like that
poster bro it was awesome she's a little
stupid though have you ever admitted
this to her uh now all right
I need to call in and do one of those
what's up boys and Chris his name's Mike
calling it from Baltimore Maryland
I got a relationship advice for you
so basically my girl goes to a
university college
and she'll go to frat parties every now
and then
and she'll end up taking pictures with
the Frat Boys and chugging with them and
doing French [ __ ] oh no as of now I
don't really mind it it's I'm not a
jealous guy so I don't I don't care much
but I know how guys think yeah and
a little thing like that may give them
an invitation to something more
and she doesn't realize that oh she does
so I want to get your guys advice on
that and should I bring light to the to
the subject or should I just keep doing
what I'm doing and let it go should I
bring the adult response first then you
guys can you know be silly okay if you
want thank you I hope she didn't just
leave us a voicemail I know right no I I
think that like as long as I just think
that he has to have a conversation with
his chick just about like don't please
don't put yourself in a compromising
situation disrespect you know I mean so
like if the girl can go so what go drink
have fun do you have partners with you
do you have people that like you you
feel safe you know because you don't
want to be in a situation drinking with
people that you don't know because it's
like because if invitation I don't agree
with that that means you're with
[ __ ] but if you are with [ __ ]
make sure you're in a safe situation
because I don't want to hear later I
wouldn't want my chick coming to me
later being like you know this thing
happened at this point yeah because then
I'm like well what the [ __ ] were you
doing at this party right you know what
I mean like it's like don't put yourself
in a compromising situation because it's
not going to be just on the other people
yeah you want the real real listen if
you're partying with Sigma Phi Alpha
everything [ __ ] Saturday doing bong
race yeah you're doing more than bong
rips you feel me she's there with the
boys ain't just looking for a friend
live her best now she's getting College
you're getting DP'd man I've seen this a
million times
you drinking Miller liking deep like you
would say every Saturday I just feel
like uh yeah what you should just have
the conversation like just so you know
this looks like this yeah just so you
know you need to know that information
like one time I was I this was maybe 11
years ago I was with this girl and she
and we were she was my girlfriend and
she had like pictures on her I think it
was Facebook Myspace of uh no Facebook
and she had uh pictures of her like on
private planes private jets and I was
like just so you know because she really
wasn't like that at all no she wasn't
and I said I said no I said where I said
you wasn't she really wasn't you know
this girl and then she for sure
hey there's only one way to get on a
plane down yeah come on private no so
let me explain this to you before you no
yeah but this is funny we want to keep
oh okay so so so I said to her I said
just so you know this looks like you're
[ __ ] guys on private planes you need
to know this and she was like oh really
and I said yes I said if you're not
doing that if you are doing that who
cares and fine but if you're not doing
that you don't want to look like that
and she's like okay she took all those
pictures down immediately well that's
nice of her but but it's like it sucks
though a chick can't just be on a
private plane
it's hard to get from I mean it's hard
it travels travels hard yeah travels
hard with your private plane to see your
kid you know what I mean would I you
just land on a reservation without
telling anybody I'd fly on a damn Eagles
back to see my son I'll tell you that I
think it's prohibited it sounds like a
great song I fly on a Eagles back you
see my son it's very too wordy but
[Applause]
to see my son don't know
as long as it's not connecting
one Eagle not two English
she's also looking for some relations
all right well what's up hey my
Sam I'm 25 I'm from New Jersey currently
at work I do real estate photography
and uh have a king eater sting it for
you guys so uh can you understand it I'm
talking to this guy I've been talking to
him for like a couple months now met on
a [ __ ] dating app haven't actually
met in person says he wants to like do
all these sexual things to me and
whatever and I haven't been attracted to
somebody like this in a really long time
so of course I'm being a dumbass and
just like going along with it and then
he won't come actually meet me on the
weekends and claims he can't have people
over because he Stills with his family
and I still live with my family so I
can't have him over catfish just like at
this point you're all barking no bite
dude like come on so can you understand
it do I just keep talking to him and
wait to see if he comes around no no no
like I'm just kind of tired of it at
this point gang gang buzz buzz Crystal
Lee I [ __ ] love you but sore yeah
she's way too cute to be like after he
the dude haven't met you in three days
out get out but you're cute for that
[ __ ] yeah well there's a few questions
that we need to understand let's go how
far away is he number one what are you
doing okay if he's if he's if he's
across the country I understand is it
tough also how long has it been she's
got a few months oh it has okay that's
too long yeah yeah if you're bad enough
then dudes like in the general area I'd
say a three to four hour plane ride he
would be there
or has a wife or some [ __ ] yeah yeah
have they face timed like like you know
like get off that like you're on the app
fine you meet someone on the app cool
but talk talk get off that [ __ ] right
away
hey what's up oh cool wow I like your
style ding dong yeah yeah hi I'm here
all I'm saying is because it's too
common it's so easy for people just to
be like you know whatever like what is
she doing she's also a pretty girl
that should be easy feel [ __ ] flying
the eagle to get through yeah dude I'd
fly on an eagles would be [ __ ] yeah
dude to watch you sit on that egg yeah
yeah wait
we don't want to talk to her on Zoom
next week
you know what no she needs to we need to
do the dating thing with her
[Music]
she should send pictures to the dude
it's probably you could reverse Google
Images my question Antonio Sabato Jr but
here's my question she's taking pictures
in like fancy houses because she's a
real estate photographer but it looks
like you know oh [ __ ] she's lying you're
saying yeah catfishing with the houses
yeah what if your girl was taking
pictures because she's a private jet
picture person you know what I mean but
she but at least we know she's pretty
that was actually her yeah but she and
catfish you know she might live in an
apartment some dope crib but what if
some guy sends a video is like hey I
have uh six kids and and a wife and I've
been sitting talking to this chick in
New Jersey she's wanting to meet up
there what should I do like I want to
know how they talked on the phone like
if you haven't seriously talked on the
phone to him he ain't reading it has to
be FaceTime right yeah yeah oh this guy
taking a [ __ ] can't get her sting it
yeah yo I got a uh kingy stingy for you
um you have to excuse my eyes because uh
they won't open
uh tattoos with no deeper meaning
um
I get people coming up to me all the
time I got a decent collection of them
they ask what they mean and uh dude they
don't mean jack [ __ ] yeah nothing worse
I got a pineapple up here it's just a
[ __ ] Pineapple yeah why not triangle
it's a triangle cool you know yeah pine
cone
you know what uh I think it's cool to
just get tied it up [ __ ] it you are a
cat guy not really I think it's good to
get tatted up do you know what you no I
think it's dope there's nothing worse
when someone goes what's that mean I
guess so I don't know you that well you
know yeah he kind of signed up for it
though did you have you ever asked
somebody with the tattoo never well
speaking of tattoos that are look
ridiculous go ahead take this one Chris
dude this is a great tattoo I have and I
know why I got it if you'd like to know
you can ask Well why'd you get it okay
uh well
so my birthday is 40 days from Calvin's
birthday and God Kristen's birthday I
hate you even have to explain this yeah
it's cool you have no tats I'm cool
you're getting a tattoo also he's got a
pine cone and pineapple that's hilarious
that's pretty good dude I think he's got
a pine tree
now it's starting to mean something he's
got what's that I think he's pretending
like it doesn't mean what's that movie
with Ryan Gosling forestry probably
return to the Pines or whatever he's got
that this guy oh yeah this is what's his
name
maybe Eric maybe Stevie I got a king
inner sting it for you guys nice movie
posters is room decor no I know it's
kind of a stereotype for guys that are
in college but I'm a guy in college
myself so and they're gonna bother me a
ton but I wanted to see what you guys
thought maybe it's not original enough
maybe it's a little corny well the band
has got a banjo uh gang gang buzz buzz
is that a
nice
sore oh to a double a pump fake with the
girls trip is that a Denny's yeah yeah
yeah
um yeah so no I think that uh yeah
you're in college that's what you do
he's probably got a Fight Club poster no
no dude not even College this is uh you
don't have a steady girlfriend that
comes over all the time and he's a good
guy
a girl needs to just go fix him up I had
to pull I have a dope Pulp Fiction
poster it's a good poster that [ __ ] is
now in the downstairs bathroom yeah yeah
yeah it seems like this guy yeah is a
good guy yeah he seems like he's a rocky
poster
he's got the Rat Pack I mean so-called I
guarantee he's a Fight Club poster I
guarantee it yeah and Scarface yes
swingers we might be too young for that
but yeah
all right good guys Good Guys quality
human being so you never have you wanna
are you you ever a poster guy oh yeah I
was yeah when I was yeah when I was in
college yeah I made anyone go to college
I have like I have sports posters like I
have a bunch of Michael Jordan posters
yeah yeah
Hudson we had a lot of different guys I
have a big ass Big Trouble in Little
China painting when you walk to my house
oh that was such a great movie
one of the best yeah
neutering your dog yeah
I got a can get her sting it for you
neutering your dog are you for it or
against it me personally I have a
neutered my dog he's two and a half
years old my vet did tell me it's not an
issue when she doesn't see a lot of
cancer and young healthy dogs I know
there's a lot of controversy against it
what do you think including your dogs
for it or against it gang gang buzz buzz
soar
say bye buddy let me see that wiener
let's see that dick well they don't cut
the dick off no but yeah
but accidentally pet weiner
um I think that uh I think honestly uh
they say it's health benefits right yes
but I'll say it's pervy Rich dude yeah
animals
is it yeah we live in this in in
Hollywood is that weird to say no no I'm
not saying it's weird to say it's a very
you thing to say yeah I said you're at
some party and you have to bring a pint
of I like how they say it doesn't really
bother the dogs really who told you that
that prep is though the dog certainly
didn't
somebody connected it to like a
monitor or something you can see when it
hurts no I bet man but also some of
those like bulldogs and big Great Danes
have them big big balls they sit on it
like one of those things in the toy
store you don't want those all over your
hands and face the other big black balls
there's a video of some kid like just
touching some animals balls over and
over again too on the internet and I
think here's the thing you cut balls off
you don't get videos like that but you
know what you can do you can snip their
their nuts and then they have
Prosthetics in the menu you know what
I'm talking about chin
they're fake nuts for your dog you can
pick bigger ones too at least one at the
restaurant I know and get Great Dane
nuts I know I know imagine if you had
wedded with restaurants and it's like so
many different types of dogs on the menu
oh the cocker spaniel is really nice
uh what is today's special it's either
them fake nuts let me see if we have any
left oh sorry yeah we're fresh out of
Bichon guys yeah yeah yeah
this is the misplay I love [ __ ] like
this you don't need the quotes it says
wrong quotes you know how many how many
people use just quotes for no reason it
wasn't jokingly before it was before it
wasn't nobody said after it's after yeah
you guys don't feel strongly about that
well [ __ ] I'll bring it over to
congratulations
maybe they was the after is the before
so it's before that dog got them could
be uh that dog got them body nuts on it
uh this guy also needs some relationship
advice
geez unless people are struggling man uh
Brennan Theo
um I know Chris and Harry get all butt
hurt we don't mention that so thank you
facts about anybody else's feelings so
[ __ ] whoever decided to show up today
Nick Chen uh Stevie cat Chappelle
[ __ ] Derek I guess that short kid in
the back you guys always make fun of
shout out him
um Jake I'm from Chicago I got a
relationship advice today
um I've been with my girl for a while
lover to death everything's going good
there
but uh I'm in law school right now so
living pretty broke boy status could
this guy be more Blossom for my dinners
you know Ubers drinks yeah
um and I want to take her out and do
cool City stuff but it's also expensive
and yeah all right daddy ain't got the
money like that I got these hand-me-down
couches you know shit's just not going
that well so uh I don't know how to feel
as a man feeling fear if you guys could
help me out uh gang gang okay it's an
investment dog you're a stock yes we'll
see what's up in 10 years not even 10
but still driving Uber and you're a
lawyer Daddy yeah and you do have money
look your time is money brother you put
your time into yourself right now and
that's what you're doing she's smart
girl she sees that and she sees you're
going to be a lawyer you're going to be
a um
uh whatever he's gonna be Frankie what
else could you be with a lawyer
judge doctor okay and another thing too
is like you don't stop putting stock
into spending money as quality yes no
just say I love you though yeah you can
take it you could like go on like nice
Walks Like if you hand made some
sandwiches and you took it to a park or
you know just find all kinds of other
[ __ ] to do yeah you can catch your
little salmon bro yeah you could do buy
that [ __ ] a fish dinner dog you know
what I'm saying treat her well and
you're doing the Long Haul thing too so
that's I'm sure attractive to her that
you're out here trying to be better the
best charges against that [ __ ] yeah
trying to be all you can be man get that
[ __ ] a McFlurry every Wednesday yeah
you're a lawyer dog monster this this is
monsters
[ __ ] monster we're trying to help
them out man make him feel good your
honor yeah
good man you're good man
you're good man you [ __ ] you're good
you're young dude you don't have money
yet because you're young you'll have
money you know I'm not gonna say
anything
almost we had to his teeth are just a
little bit too far apart
this is the last one last one you're an
[ __ ] here me I wasn't even going on
oh [ __ ] man you see how he does it yeah
man y'all taking it easy with y'all care
y'all are [ __ ] kickers bro I'm gonna
hire that lawyer sue the [ __ ] it is Sean
Paul here from Belfast there you go he's
[ __ ] Irish you folks
the girl around study clothes and I need
a
honestyles
he has four top teeth is that it
it's like your face his teeth like a
hippo I think he just moved his third
one over because he lost it wow he lost
one of them [ __ ]
it's not like you said shitty clothes
but she's saying he's saying [ __ ]
clothes if he doesn't mind it with his
girlfriend he got kicked in the face and
one of the things one of the teeth fell
out he just moved out there [ __ ] it bro
he's Irish bloody slows yeah he's Irish
he's Irish top team okay they're six
times bigger than his bottom teeth ain't
nobody else I think this guy's fine like
he looks the way he looks it's not bad
he's doing great he's Irish he's just
asking he's cool with his growing [ __ ]
clothes right he's cool he's Irish
don't be insecure about it you want your
girl to look good it's your girl yeah
but in Ireland is that like a thing
because they have like a lot of Shame
you know I don't think so but it's also
like when you guys get mad when other
dudes look at your chick like bro if
you're gonna drive a Ferrari people can
look at it I know I know but but people
stare at my girl's ass I'm like I get it
man yeah
one time I was one time I was at this I
don't remember what it was but it was
some kind of Hollywood thing and years
ago and I don't even do [ __ ] like that
and and um and so I see this really
beautiful woman walk by and then I see
holding her hand Orlando Bloom right so
I see her first and then I see it's
Orlando Bloom and Orlando Bloom looks at
me and goes and gives me a wink he's
just like like yeah I know you know
what's up you know and I was like uh
right from then on I'm like I'll watch
everything Orlando Bloom is in that was
so much all seven I watched every part
of the Caribbean every Lord of the Rings
and every whatever other movie she's
dying I know you guys have never seen
this and maybe it's on YouTube and what
is it have you seen uh this Billy eilish
uh documentary and Orlando Bloom meets
her yep and he hugs her too long creepy
style he's trying to feel the sweater
really I swear to God like I'm sure it's
on YouTube because Orlando blue goes in
on this hug oh wow that's funny such a
fan of her right he's with his girl Katy
Perry at the time it's bad too yeah here
right here yeah this is probably it
dude
is it a good documentary yeah oh yeah I
like Billy eilish so Katy Perry hugs are
hard yeah but just because you like it
doesn't mean it's a good documentary no
it's a good dog be cool man yeah but
tell me why it's a good dog oh here we
go
here he goes
there's a quick question
at the concert all right cool yeah
um
two of them I mean I get it knocked this
girl's haters shuttle School pop star
and I got the new school pop dude I went
to a movie the other day I go to the
movie and there are four people in front
of me in line and one of them was Billy
eilish going to the movies what was it
you pretty in person Orlando blue movie
no I was going to a different I don't
know what movie was it Jared Leto's dude
morbius bro I went to the premiere
actually I knew you didn't come on bro
did you see it [ __ ] no I can't wait to
though hey did you see my Lord and
Savior in person who you're letting you
got a picture with him
you post on Instagram bro the guy sent
you a picture up with him yeah yeah yeah
oh somebody took a picture of us yeah I
saw somebody took a picture of us I love
that he did the guy's name is Michael
morbius yeah bro that's so funny yeah
it's like if your name was like Chris
corvius dude oh Michael morbius like oh
oh you're the oh you're the superhero
though
back in the end of back in the 40s you
know when that was cool I know yeah he
did a good job yeah but did I thought
like these are the only two cops in the
whole city movies there was it was like
on the uh you gotta watch it there
wasn't a big cast yeah you don't need a
big cast it was weird it just was weird
why because you got Jared got all you
need yeah Jared that was actually a
really attractive man yeah but it's like
[ __ ] Jesus was a nice guy yeah we
know he's from Louisiana do we know
Jesus was a nice guy no but you know
what I'm just saying the Backstreet Boys
are good at singing It's like saying
you know Jared Little's in a truck
everybody he's in the worst Marvel movie
and the worst DC movie which is
hilarious that is hilarious I have a
game show like a party okay
you have to have a serious conversation
with somebody with pop music playing in
the background and you cannot react to
the pop music
he's 50. yeah he's 50 years old yeah get
my [ __ ] together he's fit as a feed lay
bruh he's always at the UFC's too man
yeah that's where I met him at I bet you
did I don't know about this man he's
probably like oh you're always the guy
tweeting during the paper Chris is
jealousy right now oh dude I can't he's
such a hater I'm not a hater dude the
guy's a great actor yeah he's a great
actor yeah Oscar yourself I'm not saying
he's not good but he's done some
horrible [ __ ] in the [ __ ] movies and
he dresses like a complete
fool come on not every episode of
congratulations is great you know what I
mean yeah look I will say this he
definitely has so much tire that hey he
has like a very hot mama tire at times
yeah but he the future yeah you dressed
like a cool jacket oh yeah he's trying
to like how he goes can I mess this up
let me try yeah it's like almost like
it's like I'm gonna try to [ __ ] this up
today and see if I can't get anything
you know what the Grammys he just wore a
suit no shirt but wait I'm tired of you
saying I'm a [ __ ] hater because I'm
not there you are say one good thing
about him look at this [ __ ] here we go
here we go look at this [ __ ] dude it's
the met guys
I don't give a [ __ ] what it is how about
that dude I'm just kidding Chris you
could I could see you in this he looks
like yeah but I've been doing it as a
joke he looks like one of those um
congratulations is good for China is he
looks like a Faberge egg and this the
guy's a [ __ ] chandelier but he also
he oh he wildly looks he's a vampire he
looks like a handsome man and a hot
chick at the same time and that's
already really rich people can afford it
though people like is
I'm confused him through this hooked up
like this
it's like Bill games
spot on gang gang yeah it's tough
because he's a really pretty girl or a
handsome dude I'm confused
glasses of wine this is obviously some
kind of point he's trying to make so I'm
okay with it
guys Ken what do you think in your
culture what do you guys do with this if
I kill him this is the outfit yeah yes I
think no kings and queens usually they
actually dressed kind of like that
because this is what makes people hate
Hollywood bro yeah it's like this is so
stupid inside of touch I don't give a
[ __ ] if it's in that guy but he's that
guy
use the face of Gucci everybody's that
guy now dude no not everybody but
everybody but everybody's trying to be
this [ __ ] they're trying fantastic
version they're trying to be him it's
just annoying what does the head mean I
just
it's art man you guys don't know man I
don't know art you don't know I know
Jared let me know you don't know you
know he knows you didn't see more
morbius he went to [ __ ] the premiere
he saw it I don't go to the movies I
paid to see it I don't go to movies I'm
not like I enjoyed it I had a nice now
this is completely different okay about
this this is different now this is who
is this uh David Alan Greer no
I can't wait to clip this and send it to
David it's beautiful I love that guy
um yeah he's great yeah that's different
though see Jared Leto wouldn't do that
okay you know that's that guy's trying
to be glamorous yeah that's a gay man
that's his feminine glamorousness he's
doing Jared Leto's trying to do like
some sort of like he walks of fun
this guy looks like Amelia Bastille your
man that's what that dude looks like
right there that's David Alan Grier when
he was 60. I love it he's like 175 now
David Alan Grier was a legendary
David Alan Greer is a is a legend this
is completely different like if Jared
Leto was doing that it's like Harry
Styles is always doing this like like I
don't believe I don't believe Harry
Styles like like Jared Leto's doing
something weird he's got the head Harry
Styles is like is doing this sort of
like I don't know what you're saying
you're saying you believe Jared letters
yeah because he's doing some kind of
thing even though for a year he's been
famous since let's move on I love the I
love Jared Leto I love David Allen too
that's not David Alan Greer that's all
we got Phoenix I'm gonna be April 30th
I'm gonna be in Phoenix go get those
tickets crystalia.com Phoenix I'll be
there I don't know where I'm at and I'm
there right before Chris April 14th
through the 16th stand up live Phoenix
Arizona then Austin Texas April 22nd the
23rd Moontower Comedy Festival I'm
opening up the new cap cities out there
come get something else in Texas and
then April 28th the special drops on
thick boys stay tuned
and the intro's dope so check that out
I got a show in uh May 7 in Los Angeles
at The Wiltern you can see it and then
Albuquerque Albuquerque Midland Texas a
little bit Texas
and Dallas Texas that's May August 18th
through the 21st and then we'll be
heading down to Savannah Georgia
Montgomery second June 3rd at Augusta uh
June 4 in Montgomery Alabama and June 5
over there in Columbus GA at the bill
herd theater hey can I say this because
Theo's not going to say it's nothing for
me she feels moving into a different
level now you're at a certain level and
you're nervous to do a big tour like
this man so come out and see Theo man
he's taking a risk and he was nervous
about it and uh show him some support
man get out there and buy those tickets
he's trying to get to the next level and
this is it man these these venues are
different freaking level man no matter
what happens
where are you going to be in Arizona
yeah come on by I'm gonna show up there
[Laughter]
we love you guys keep subscribing keep
going to it man we're giving you
something yeah
check out ripping with Griffin you can
see that every what day does it come out
I do it on Tuesdays on Tuesdays I gotta
go home right now and do it all right
kids love you bye-bye
[Music]
all night long how many times I gotta
make this song
wait I get the gist I just probably have
to slow it down and hit it like this
[Music]
thing in the way let's go legendary